- [Interviewer] All right, Todd.
- Yeah, how you doing?
- [Interviewer] Welcome back.
- Well, thank you for having me back.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] So it's been,
I don't know how many months,
four or five months I think,
- Yeah, the least.
- Since we spoke last.
- [Todd] I'm coming up on a year here.
- [Interviewer] You've been
well, the last time we spoke,
I was giving you a little
extra money to go to San Diego
- And I did appreciate it.
And I was.
- [Interviewer] But you didn't
- Well,
part of the reason I
came here to LA was to,
I had a bunch of hits.
My wife had me arrested,
cost me five grand.
My truck got stolen, it was just,
My other truck broke down.
It was just like, I kept getting
hit after hit, after hit.
And I came here and I
said, I'm not leaving here.
I came here for a weekend.
I do my little hustle thing and
I said, I'm not leaving here
until I come up and get back in the road.
I do construction and I
can make as much money
as I want in construction.
I'm very, very good and I was part owner
of a contracting company.
But when I'm using my
drug of choice, crack,
and that's all I do,
I don't do that 'cause
I'm not accountable.
I might not show up on a job
one day and this and that
and it burned bridges.
So I do hustle
and I do rather well at that too.
I do rather well at anything I do.
I'm extremist
- [Interviewer] You just
showed me some photos of your,
So most people that live on
Skid Row have little tents.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Crappy
little tents that are just,
- I've always wanted to build one.
When I got here, that
was one of the things
that caught me, I mean, these
people are just San Diego,
you come from San Diego.
You can't just pop up a
tent and just leave it.
You gotta take it down every morning
at a certain time,
Yeah I come down here and
these guys are like, wow
- [Interviewer] But you just showed me
your tent where you use some
of your construction know how.
- Exactly I had a front door.
- [Interviewer] You had a unit door?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You had
a barbecue grill inside,
you had,
- Barbecue with the hood exhaust.
I had a full on shower.
New water tank,
- [Interviewer] You have running water?
- I had a tank with a pump
and it heats the water.
So that worked out great.
You know, I had a
microwave, AC, refrigerator,
- [Interviewer] You had air conditioning?
- Yeah and also two full,
well one small TV and
one big full screen TV,
- [Interviewer] So that
means you have a lots
of female companionship?
- Yeah, you can't get em out of there.
Everybody that comes there
they just, it become overwhelming.
They just, you mean,
like I think I say that before
they, this whole place
will just suck you dry.
I mean, everybody is after something.
You know what I mean,
I try to main maintain myself.
I'm the type of person.
I just, I got it from my mom.
She's I just like helping
people, you know what I mean?
And the more I help
people, the more they take
the more they want, the more they've.
And I am not
- [Interviewer] I've learned that,
I become the ATM machine for everybody.
- I see that, it just kills me.
Yeah, anyway, what was I gonna say is,
- [Interviewer] So the police
figured out what you're doing.
- Well one of my hustles became here.
People, I built three different places,
layers or whatever you wanna call them.
And everybody raved and
they all wanted them
and they all none wanna leave.
So that become of I'm not type of person,
that want a bunch of people around
maybe a female companion
and this and that.
They just wouldn't stop
knocking on the door.
They just don't.
You know what I mean?
And another thing I'm very hosting
I always have food and this and that.
And they, I always feed
everybody or whatever.
I try it.
Try to help people.
You know what I mean?
But down here they will just suck you dry.
But anyways, back to my place,
the guy in the back of the building
where he don't own the sidewalk
but I'm in front of his area
he came and talked to me and said,
wow (mumbling)
you're the guy that owns the mansion?
And I'm like, yeah if
you wanna call it that.
So he said, I'm having
a problem with my gate.
I addressed it, reframe things.
And the part of the problem
was I framed a wall.
I've had other places
people just cut the
tent and steal my tools.
I've lost, not thousands of dollars
10 thousands of dollars of stuff.
I am not kidding.
There'd be every day here,
I take some kind of hit,
everyday, but I just kind of brush it off.
'Cause I'm good at what
I do and just move on.
And, but it is taking a toll on me.
Well, not just the Skid Roll
people have sucked me dry.
LAPD did a hit on me pretty good.
That little area that area
that I had is probably between,
honestly between seven and
$10,000 worth of stuff.
It was 4,000 just for the
lumber that I put in there.
And it was kind of, but
I liked doing what I do
- [Interviewer] But it looked like a tent.
- It looked like a tent.
- [Interviewer] You had the tent exterior,
but inside was the,
- Yeah I had a real front door
but I had a car, draping it, and then
- [Interviewer] You drive by
you'll think it was a tent.
- That was my idea.
But yeah.
- [Interviewer] But
inside it was actually a,
- It was a framed walls.
- [Interviewer] It was there.
- It was secure.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Someone couldn't just,
anybody get in any anything.
Well, it takes some effort.
- [Interviewer] I'm assuming,
- I had cameras too.
- [Interviewer] And you had a bed?
- Yeah Memory Foam.
It was all nice.
But the pictures I showed
you, it wasn't even complete.
I had this one.
There's some talent people down here.
I had this one lady had a drapery.
She put some art on it and stuff
and I was gonna have
her do the whole place.
You what I mean,
so, but one of the major no-nos here
and one of my other
hustles here is hooking up
power for people.
On here on Skid Roll.
And they have it everywhere.
The problem is with me.
I mean, there's a guy down the
street, he's off the street.
I keep my place very clean.
When LAPD came in,
they said,
they're were worried
about the Corona viruses.
We aint gonna worry about
no Corona virus here.
This place is spotless.
(laughing)
I bleach, I clean everything.
- [Interviewer] The police
were impressed with you?
- The whole police department
after they arrested me
and took me to jail for
hooking into the power.
So they came the day
before and I wasn't there.
And they told, they misled my neighbor
and said they were maintenance guys.
And they need to get
into one of the boxes.
Well, my layer was over the box.
So that night I stood up all night
and refrained and moved the door back.
So the boxes were clear.
So the next day they came back and said,
well these guys ain't
maintenance, this is the city.
And they pulled in with
cops two big dump trucks.
I mean, they had like
four or five crews here
and I'm like what the F!
And they said, well,
this thing is you know
we can't have it because it
doesn't collapse three feet.
That's the code.
You gotta have three feet.
And I said, I'm looking down the street.
And I'm looking at all
these places all off
the street and you know
why they fucking with me.
While the manager or the supervisor
and the foreman came over one day
and told me I had to
expose the box so I did.
And I was trying to accommodate him.
And he goes, wow, this man,
you live better than I do.
So can I take a picture?
So we took some pictures,
when he was taking a picture
of was the shower, the
electrical stuff I was using.
So he called the city
and told them I'm stealing their water
and their electricity.
So I never heard of
anybody down here almost
been here a year now came for a weekend.
I'm almost been here a year.
- [Interviewer] You come for a weekend?
- Came just for the weekend honestly.
- [Interviewer] And
you've been here a year?
- Yeah, I had a $50,000 job going.
I have my, I have a handicapped child,
with the mother gone along way.
I have a wife,
for the last 10 years it's been hell
'cause she got in her addiction too.
So she finally, I finally picked up
I haven't talked to my twin brother,
I haven't talked to the only person I talk
to is my youngest son in Long Beach.
And so I finally started
talking to people just recently.
And she came up, I got her to come up.
And when I left, she had me arrested.
She had me just putting sugar in my tank,
just anything she could do to destroy me.
She would do it.
And cause she was very jealous
and she loved me very much
that she would do these things.
And so she came up, I was like well wait,
maybe things are she
wanted me to come home.
I said, why don't you come up here?
I wanted to show her my place.
That didn't go for very well,
'cause now I got all
these bitches up in here.
That was her first thinking.
She was right, you know what I mean?
So I say, there ain't
nobody coming up in here
and I won't do all that.
And then so, she started same thing.
She started in windows.
You better not have no cameras
on me and just to start.
And when she would do this
before my stomach would turn
my back was starting to go out.
I mean, she would physically affect me.
That's when I knew we needed to get away.
And for my wellbeing
because she was destroying
everything of mine
calling customers up,
telling him I'm screwing them
and this and that,
you know, clients,
that I'm doing work for.
So when I was up here.
- This is your wife?
- This is my wife.
And I love her so much.
I've been known over 20 years
and she started hitting
and first thing
my stomach started turning
I said man, this needs aint changing,
it aint changing and
it's not gonna change.
She's made so much drama.
I had to drag her out of my
place and tell her to leave.
Because the street I'm on.
The reason I like that
street it's regulated,
by certain people.
They keep it quiet.
They keep, they don't want attention
because they do their thing
and they don't want none of that going on.
And sure enough, they heard,
we didn't hear you.
We heard her.
And cause she gets, she makes drama.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] So your
new life that you have here
on the street and Skid
Row, I mean are you happy?
- I wouldn't say I'm happy
cause I've been going
through a lot of depression.
I have a hard time
getting up in the morning,
because I just don't wanna get up,
but once I get moving I'm,
but so I'm not gonna say I'm happy.
I got comfortable here
because of my addiction.
It's easy to get things.
The female thing just
become way overwhelming.
You know what I mean?
Because of the layer is just like, I mean,
You don't see too many,
honestly you don't see a whole
lot of white guys down here.
- [Interviewer] No.
- You don't.
- [Interviewer] I stand
out like a sore thumb.
Some of them are on my target.
I've been around a little bit
especially from doing my drug of choice,
dealing with a bunch of different people.
A lot of people think I'm naive.
I let them believe I'm naive.
You know what I mean?
I just, if they do me dirty,
I won't I just will not
deal with them again.
They've all learned that,
I will not deal with you ever again.
If you do me dirty.
So in a lot of almost everybody here.
- [Interviewer] So how are
you supporting yourself now?
How are you living?
What are you living off of?
- Well,
- [Interviewer] You have savings?
- No.
I live right here.
I live day to day, but like
I said I do rather well,
what I do,
I may,
when I have a vehicle
the police have took all,
they bought the quaint
in, destroyed everything.
They're supposed to pack your property up.
Like I said, I had between
seven to $10,000 worth of stuff.
- [Interviewer] They destroyed your layer.
- They destroyed, the layer.
There's, it is all only
concrete there now.
I just got arrested the other day for it.
- [Interviewer] And so,
- They took my truck.
- [Interviewer] Last
night, you slept where?
- I slept on a reduced me down to
a somebody gave me a
little one or two man tent.
That's what I'm on.
And with it empty, I have no vehicle,
the vehicle, they weren't
gonna tow my truck.
But somebody broke into
and busted the locks.
Prior to that, I think
I told you this story.
I was drugged and mugged in Long Beach.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Well, they took all my paperwork
and when they busted my
ignition and everything else.
And so they weren't gonna tow my truck,
they said well
how do you get in the truck?
I said, well, you got to
get the wire and do this.
And no ignition, no paperwork.
And they said, no, no, no, no, no.
We're in pounding this truck.
They thought it was stolen.
I said, all you gotta do is
check Long Beach records.
They'll tell you my truck was stolen.
Who owns the car.
So of course they weren't
gonna do all that.
They towed the car.
So now I have no car, no
place to live, no nothing.
I'm literally on the sidewalk.
They, I picked up
I don't know if you're
familiar with the bin.
When they take all your stuff here
they're supposed to
itemize and bag every item
and they take it to the bin
and then you'd go down and pick it up.
So I'm on the sidewalk
with 16 bags of stuff,
which eight of the bags
are somebody else's.
'Cause I was storing their stuff there.
So I had eight bags of stuff left
and none of it's not even my clothes.
It's all just, it's another.
They either made a
reason throw things away.
I said, what'd you do in my brand new,
I cornered the guy, seen him the next day,
who was in charge of loading stuff.
And he said, well the barbecue pit,
we couldn't get the five gallon
because Hazmat won't let you
do like gas tanks and things like that.
They couldn't get the tank off.
So they threw the barbecue away.
$400 barbecue.
I said, it's brand new.
Every barbecue has a little
screw to holds the tank
in place.
And it wasn't even tight and
you couldn't get the tank off.
So you decided to throw
it away or keep it.
So it goes on and on a number
of lot of expensive stuff,
tools are missing,
the water heater.
The, goes on my AC,
- [Interviewer] Technically
you're a homeless person?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I never considered,
I told the cops, I sold your home.
I said, well I really
didn't consider my home
being homeless until now.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] You didn't own
the property that you were.
- I didn't own it, but I was squatting.
Sort of a squatter I guess, but
- [Interviewer] So the
moral of this story is what?
That crack's a hell of a drug.
- Yeah, yeah
Well that's the main
reason it's kept me here.
That is the crap and all the things a bit
everything has been revolved around it.
My whole life has been
about the crack business
I've been here,
I mean it's so,
I mean I could go to any corner.
I don't even have to make
it to the corner to find it.
You know what I mean,
- [Interviewer] And getting
cleaned is not something that's
in the cards is it?
- Well this is when I left San Diego.
I was doing, I was doing construction
and also doing my HUC
coming here on the weekend,
doing my hustle.`
And I was making a lot of money.
I was doing at least a
quarter ounce of crack a day.
That's unheard of,
That's unheard of.
That's seven grams of crack a day
myself from the day at times I got
- [Interviewer] Hold on, how much?
- Seven grams.
- A day?
- A day of crack myself.
Most people would do 40 or 60.
And I know my addiction.
I've gotten cleaned a lot of times.
And I'm about on the verge
of going into program.
And I'm about the verge
to go back to San Diego
but I'm not gonna go back.
I'm not gonna go back, using,
I'm gonna go back clean.
That's what I wanna do.
So yeah, I'm not using
a ounce of crack now.
But I'd still use at
least two, $300 a day.
You asked how I survive?
I make that and survive.
What food get a day.
You know what I mean?
And I do live day by day.
I don't plan, well tomorrow.
I know enough to where I can.
I know I'm gonna get money tomorrow
at least that's my thinking,
you know what I mean?
And so it's really a sick thing.
It really is and its just.
And I know this has been my longest run
and this has been the most usage per day
that I've ever done.
I function very well on it.
- [Interviewer] What
does crack do for you?
- Been asking,
I've been doing it a long time
What it does for me?
It blocks everything out.
I get up in the morning.
I take a, I've been going
through a lot of depression.
I get up, I start thinking
about my family and this why.
I asked myself every day,
what am I doing here?
Why am I here?
And it blocks everything out.
It allows me to do what I do.
As far as the hustle
I can't do it straight sober,
and I don't sell myself.
Just so you know,
(laughing)
the other night,
right after this all
happened, I was down and out.
- [Interviewer] No you gotta
describe what your hustle is
to me off camera.
So we won't get into that.
- I don't wanna get into that.
That might be incriminating.
But anyways, I'm very good at it though.
Do you need any tools?
(laughing)
I see you guys anyway.
So I'm down and out.
I wasn't this guy, I had no money.
Couldn't get no crack.
So this guy pulls up and he's,
hey the Mexican wants you.
And I'm like, what's me,
what does he want me for?
I don't know him.
So I walk up to the car and he says,
Hey I am looking for, you do Crystal?
I said no don't fuck around.
I said I do Cavy,
they call the crack Cavy here
and he said okay,
I like guys.
I said, good for you, good for you.
He goes, I'll get you
some Cavy and pay you.
Let me suck your Dick.
I ain't going out like that.
I'm not, can't even do
it and I turned around,
I walked away.
I'm not, would not bring myself to that.
You know what I mean?
That's just not me.
But that was funny.
I got proposed.
Someone made a proposal to me,
- [Interviewer] All kinds
of ways to make money here.
There's all kinds of ways to make
- There's all kinds of
way to make money here.
It's amazing.
But I'm a little unique.
I don't do anything here to make money.
- [Interviewer] So you
think you're on your way
to getting clean?
- That's where I'm heading yes.
I've been here almost a year.
My son it's I haven't talked to family
I haven't talked to anybody
and it's just I keep
asking, why am I here?
I know I'm here.
I'm stuck.
You know what I mean?
I'm stuck on.
I know if I go back to San Diego
I can't make the money to survive
to do what would in there.
No, I can do construction.
But like I said
when I get fall on
working, I'm a workaholic.
I know I'm extremist.
I do.
I go after everything all the way.
So when I go back, I have to
start working full on again
and I need to be clean to do that.
You know what I mean?
Cause normally when I'm doing construction
I'm running jobs.
First thing they, you know,
they'll hire me or whatever.
And work has never been a problem for me,
even the San Diego museum,
what are you doing?
And do you know how many
times I've heard this line
if I could do what you can do,
I'd be a millionaire by now.
I should have been a millionaire.
My partner says Todd, Todd
he used to buy me crack
just to keep me wanting
to keep me working.
I ran the whole company.
You know what I mean?
And I just said,
I've heard it over and over.
LAPD they say,
I'd be a millionaire right now.
If I knew what you could
do, you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Great but
the crack gets out of control
doesn't it?
- Well, I'm just, it
definitely gets out of control
I'm not gonna deny that,
I'm very functional on it today.
I do so much.
It don't even phase me,
but when I'm not doing it
the depression and then
I just, I just I'll go
through a heavy, heavy mood swings.
I know it's not like the heroin addicts.
I don't get sick, physically
sick, this and that
but I haven't done it over two years.
I've done it every day.
There hasn't been a day I haven't done it.
Sooner I go into panic.
Soon as I know that, I'm not
gonna, even though I don't
affect me, you know what I mean?
I did a hit before coming here.
I'm fine.
You know what I mean?
Most some people just
get, they just I mean
I've seen people, they
just can't handle it.
They're lacking on the ground.
- [Interviewer] Cracks an
excellent drug, isn't it?
Cracks an interesting drug.
- It's right up there with heroine
- [Interviewer] Cause you
can be very functional on it.
It seems.
- No,
[Interviewer] No,
- People don't function very well on it.
Yeah I mean, it's not
like heroin where you're
not now and this and that
but you get a fria when you do crack.
It doesn't last very long.
That's why the worst thing
about crack is the one
thing I did like it when I first tried it.
Cause I used just snort
powder is you want it,
you want more,
immediately you want
more and more and more
and more and more.
There's not enough crack in the world
you just keep one more and more and more.
And that's why people feed on it so much.
And they do stupid stuff.
You know what I mean?
And they rob and steal people from people.
But that's what I don't do.
I don't rob from people.
- [Interviewer] But it's
a very different drug
than crystal meth or heroin
- Yeah, yeah, Crystal meth, I've been
around crystal meth is a whole
nother whole nother ballgame.
You know what I mean?
The thing with that is the foria
of being up for so many days.
That's where you start
losing it on that stuff.
And then people, I just don't man.
They have no sense of time.
They're just there you know what I mean?
So I don't, I've tried crystal meth.
I don't care for it.
It just does nothing for me.
I thought maybe I didn't
smoke enough of it one day
I sat down and continued
just smoking the shit
because I know a lot of
people convert from crack
and then they start doing crystal meth
my twin brother's one of them,
I won't mention his name.
He's not doing real well either.
When I was at the police department,
they pulled out a file about that thick
when he's, we're twins and
we've used each other's names.
So when we get arrested,
both our records come up
they think we're the one
person that I told them.
It's my twin brother.
They didn't believe me
but he's got a number of
warrants out right now.
He's I haven't talked to
him since I've been here
and he's on the run and
he does rather well too.
He's very talented.
I have an older brother
and a younger brother.
Very talented.
We do know,
- [Interviewer] Four
brothers in the family?
- I have an older brother
and a twin brother two.
And I'm the youngest yeah.
- [Interviewer] The addiction
has hit two of those three?
- All three.
- [Interviewer] All three,
- Yeah, one time were all
in prison at the same time.
- [Interviewer] And
what about your parents?
- Did they use drugs?
No, no.
My dad was a well actually both
my parents were into sales.
My dad was German.
He moved around a lot.
He wasn't much in our life,
but he partied a little bit
but he did do drugs, but very
little and he maintained.
He never really let it
get to get ahold of him.
He just snorted Coke
and maybe smoke a little
weed or something like that.
My mom never did drugs.
So there was no,
there was no really no
problems in the childhood
or anything like that.
It's just, when I grew up in the 80's,
everybody did Coke, everybody.
There wasn't one person I
knew they didn't do Coke.
It was so abundant.
I mean, that's when it would just
it was really hitting hard,
in the 90's they started to realize,
We got a problem here.
But and back then the Coke was Coke today.
I don't even know what the hell it is.
That's a scary thing down here.
I didn't wanna touch base.
You don't know what
you're getting down here.
I mean, cause they sell fentanyl,
they sell heroin.
They sell and they put
in a little bit of shit
into everything.
That's very scary.
You know what I mean?
One day I grabbed somebody,
cause fentanyl is white.
I threw some stuff.
It was laying there.
They left it, in my pipe
and I immediately burned it
and smelled it.
I didn't, luckily I didn't hit it.
It was fentanyl.
And I've number people
- [Interviewer] You could
have died from that right?
- Yes.
A lot of people here
the main thing that taking
people out here is the fentanyl.
I hear it all the time.
At least at least twice a week.
I hear how somebody and I asked,
well what was it a fentanyl?
Sure enough.
You know, if it ain't that,
it just cause
it ain't no catwalk down here
just the other night.
You have to have
you have to keep your
awareness all the time
because you don't know what element
you're dealing with this and that.
I'm walking down and talking to somebody
and there's some commotion going on
just right at the corner.
And I'm just,
and that person said, Hey stop.
I'm trying to see what's going on here.
I said, well, that's it.
They're just arguing.
I know who's arguing.
Next is gonna be a gunfire
right after that boom!
They shot off some fight fire,
it was a gun.
And I just, it just woke me up.
You have your awareness
around here I mean.
I don't know if somebody got
I don't think somebody got shot,
but I know they were shot at,
cops came on immediately right after that.
So, and that happens quite a bit.
It's just people, it's just the mentality
of people are down here
is so different there.
I was telling the guy, he was
telling me how he had to sleep
with his big knife and how
he couldn't sleep in one area
at one too long because
someone's gonna get him.
I said, you know, that's really fucked up.
You gotta think like that,
or live like that.
I don't live like that down here.
I lived rather comfortably until,
LAPD decided take care everything of mine
But they did me, my truckload
I didn't care about I
could build another layer
or whatever the truck is,
what I used to to hustle.
So they impounded that they
only know if I'm gonna be able
to get it back.
But I guess the moral of the
thing is I think I finally got
I'm gonna,
I'm not gonna leave.
I'm gonna put myself in a program here
and then leave and go back clean.
And I do rather well in programs
whatever I do I do to the fullest.
- [Interviewer] You do well.
- I do.
- [Interviewer] You're like me.
- Is that how you are?
I'm extremists I guess.
- [Interviewer] No I recognize
that the first time we spoke,
it's like when I do
something, I either don't care
and don't do anything or
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] 100%,
- That's me right there.
I go all out and I don't.
And I,
most people, I mean, I
am a small frame guy.
Most people don't keep up
with me when I'm working
they can't hang,
Okay, I'm gonna do this today.
And I'm on that until it's done.
You know what I mean?
But yeah.
You don't know how many
people I've talked to?
What are you doing here?
I came here and I got stuck.
So many people get stuck down here.
I don't know.
You know, it's not, there's
really nothing besides
- [Interviewer] What do
you think the core reason
for all this.
- The addictions.
- [Interviewer] No I know,
but on a deeper level,
it's not just the drug addiction.
It's there's something that's making them
- What?
It's so convenient.
It's convenient down here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah you don't
have any responsibilities.
- None only what you
wanna put on yourself.
You know what I mean?
Some of them don't even
choose to have be responsible
for a tent.
They just sleep on the sidewalk.
You know what I mean?
And they don't just, I
mean trash, anything.
It's just, you know,
I can't live like that.
Even down here, I don't live like that.
I mean, I very clean very, but right now
I'm reduced to a one
man tent and trash but
- [Interviewer] It's
time to go to program.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I think I hit the bottom.
- [Interviewer] Thanks to the LAPD.
- Do you think?
But I'm telling you,
they were impressed.
- [Interviewer] I don't
think anyone had a layer
like you did.
- No that's what, the
first thing they said.
Basically, you can't be just,
you can't be just framing
shit up and doing all that.
I was gonna make it a will.
So when they pulled this shit,
I just rolled it right off.
But it was gonna,
the way I was gonna do it.
I was gonna do it right.
It was gonna cost a lot of money.
And that's now I'm not gonna do that.
I'll just, I had a (mumbles)
wasn't on the concrete.
I was on a deck.
I built a deck first, then
put the walls in the Connie's
and everything on there.
So it was a lot of money,
but I knew it was gonna
come down to either
I had to move it or tear
it down or something,
but they didn't give me the opportunity
to tear it down, they just tore it down
and I didn't get none of my stuff back.
So I am gonna go file a claim
and go after the city
for how they handled that
- [Interviewer] You're
not the property owner so,
you'll have a hard time there.
You're not a property owner.
So you'll have a hard time.
- Well, no, it's not.
I'm not going after the property.
I'm going after my belongings.
They're supposed to bag and
itemize every belonging.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- That's there is guidelines, you know?
Well, even the homeless have rights.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I guess they do.
- They do.
So and in most,
and what they do is what they
do is they keep half the stuff
or they give it away or whatever,
whatever they do with it.
Most people down here
don't pursue anything.
They just, you know what I mean?
They don't lose enough to pursue
or they just don't care anyways.
And so they know this and they don't
they do whatever they wanna do.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- I'm pursuing it.
I'm pursuing it, because
they did it wrong.
They didn't give me
they didn't give me no, really no warning.
You know, they should allowed me to do
to tear it down myself.
- [Interviewer] Todd I think
there might be better fights
to fight for you.
- [Interviewer] You
know what, anybody else,
I probably wouldn't listen,
but you're probably right.
But I'm pursuing it anyways.
(laughing)
They did.
They I don't think they did that right.
And they're supposedly,
but I'm gonna research it
before I go make an idiot of myself.
What the guidelines are, what
they you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] I admire your courage
for coming back and telling
your story of debauchery.
- No problem.
It was a pleasure.
I just, I felt impelled that
cause I told you I was leaving.
It was four or five months ago.
- [Interviewer] I think you're
cut from a different cloth
than most of the people
I interviewed down here.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're kind of like,
it's like what are you doing down here?
You're just having a crazy weekend.
Last time I met you and now you're
- Yeah, It's, it's gone into this.
Well, like I said, the wife ain't changing
and I haven't been able
to been to get away
from that relationship for years.
So she came up and showed me,
she it was gonna be the same
shit over and over again.
It ain't gonna change.
I just said, well, LA has
done one thing for me.
It's helped me get away from my wife.
I still love her.
If I go to San Diego,
probably go back to her.
You know what I mean?
But she's to my wellbeing.
She's just no good.
I mean, even as much as I love her,
I just it's so I discovered
while LA at least
did that for me.
So what I haven't found
true love down here yet.
- [Interviewer] That's gonna be hard.
- Yeah that's gonna be real hard.
- Yeah.
Because I really am.
You know, even though yeah.
You're not gonna believe this
I've been with so many
different prostitutes here
you ain't gonna believe this line.
And I know she ain't gonna believe it.
If she sees this video, I
haven't screwed none of them.
- [Interviewer] You haven't what?
- I have not screwed any of them
- [Interviewer] You haven't?
- No.
- [Interviewer] So what
do you do with them?
- Just a little companionship.
My intent is to screw (laughing)
By the time I get done,
I just, I can't do it.
I paid thousands and thousands
of dollars to these hoes.
And I can't do it.
That's the thing.
I don't hold anything.
Everybody's trying to survive down here.
You know what I mean?
A lot of them don't have means to survive.
So they just do everybody dirty.
You know what I mean?
And you know
which is not a good place to
be just doing everybody dirty
because you're gonna end up getting shot
or something's gonna happen.
You know what I mean?
I wanna try to do nobody dirty down here,
No don't do anybody dirty period.
but that's just the way it is down here.
Life on Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] All right Todd
Well, I wish you the best
of luck in your program,
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And with life.
- Okay, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
Hopefully we wont have to
have another interview.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] I hope not.